on the chair GPT side it says
the dialog format
makes it possible for Chad gbt to answer
follow-up questions admit its mistakes
challenge incorrect premises and reject
inappropriate requests but also there's
a feeling like it's struggling with
ideas
yeah it's always tempting to
anthropomorphize this stuff too much but
I also feel that way maybe I'll I'll
take a small tangent towards Jordan
Peterson who posted on Twitter
this kind of uh political question
everyone has a different question they
want to ask jgpt first right like
the different directions you want to try
the dark thing it somehow says a lot
about people the first thing the first
oh no oh no we don't I mean we don't
have to review what I do not
um I of course ask mathematical
questions and never ask anything dark
um but Jordan uh asked it uh to say
positive things about uh the current
President Joe Biden and the previous
president Donald Trump and then
he asked GPT as a follow-up to say how
many characters
how long is the string that you
generated and he showed that the
response that contained positive things
about Biden was much longer or longer
than uh that about Trump
and Jordan asked the system to can you
rewrite it with an equal number equal
length string which all of this is just
remarkable to me that it understood but
it failed to do it
and it was interesting gbt Chad GPT I
think that was 3.5 based uh was kind of
introspective about yeah it seems like I
failed to do the job correctly
and Jordan framed it as uh chai GPT was
lying and aware that it's lying
but that framing that's a human
entrepreneurization I think
um but that that that kind of yeah there
seemed to be a struggle within GPT to
understand
how to do
like what it means to generate
a text of the same length
in an answer to a question
and also in a sequence of prompts how to
understand that it failed to do so
previously and where it succeeded and
all of those like multi like parallel
reasonings that it's doing it just seems
like it's struggling so two separate
things going on here number one some of
the things that seem like they should be
obvious and easy these models really
struggle with yeah so I haven't seen
this particular example but counting
characters counting words that sort of
stuff that is hard for these models to
do well the way they're architected that
won't be very accurate
second we are building in public and we
are putting out technology
because we think it is important for the
world to get access to this early to
shape the way it's going to be developed
to help us find the good things and the
bad things and every time we put out a
new model and we just really felt this
with gpd4 this week the collective
intelligence and ability of the outside
world helps us discover things we cannot
imagine we could have never done
internally
and both like great things that the
model can do new capabilities and real
weaknesses we have to fix and so this
iterative process of putting things out
finding the the the the great Parts the
bad parts improving them quickly and
giving people time to feel the
technology and shape it with us and
provide feedback we believe is really
important the trade-off of that
is the trade-off of building in public
which is we put out things that are
going to be deeply imperfect we want to
make our mistakes while the stakes are
low we want to get it better and better
each rep but
the like the bias of chat GPT when it
launched with 3.5 was not something that
I certainly felt proud of
it's gotten much better with gpt4 many
of the critics and I really respect this
have said hey a lot of the problems that
I had with 3.5 are much better and for
um but also no two people are ever going
to agree that one single model is
unbiased on every topic and I think the
answer there is just going to be to give
users more personalized control granular
control over time
and I should say on this point you know
I've gotten to know Jordan Peterson and
um I tried to talk to GPT for about
Jordan Peterson and I asked it if Jordan
Peterson is a fascist
first of all it gave context it
described actual like description of who
Jordan Peterson is his career
psychologist and so on it it stated that
uh some number of people have called
Jordan Peterson a fascist but there is
no factual grounding to those claims and
it described a bunch of stuff that
Jordan believes like he's been an
outspoken critic of various totalitarian
um
ideologies and he believes in of
individualism and uh various freedoms
that are contradict the ideology of
fascism and so on and it goes on and on
like really nicely and it wraps it up
it's like a it's a college essay I was
like one thing that I hope these models
can do is bring some Nuance back to the
world yes it felt it felt really new you
know Twitter kind of destroyed some and
maybe we can get some back now that
really is exciting to me like for
example I asked um of course
um you know did uh did the covet virus
leak from a lab again answer very
nuanced there's two hypotheses it like
describe them it described the uh the
amount of data that's available for each
it was like
it was like a breath of fresh air when I
was a little kid I thought building AI
we didn't really call it AGI at the time
I thought building yeah I'd be like the
coolest thing ever I never never really
thought I would get the chance to work
on it but if you had told me that not
only I would get the chance to work on
it but that after making like a very
very larval Proto AGI thing that the
thing I'd have to spend my time on is
you know trying to like argue with
people about whether the number of
characters it said nice things about one
person was different than the number of
characters that said nice about some
other person if you hand people an AGI
and that's what they want to do I
wouldn't have believed you but I
understand it more now and I do have
empathy for it so what you're implying
in that statement is we took such John
leaps on the big stuff and we're
complaining or arguing about small stuff
well the small stuff is the big stuff in
aggregate so I get it it's just like I
and I also like I get why this is such
an important issue this is a really
important issue but that somehow we like
somehow this is the thing that we get
caught up in versus like what is this
going to mean for our future now maybe
you say
this is critical to what this is going
to mean for our future the thing that it
says more characters about this person
than this person and who's deciding that
and how it's being decided and how the
users get control over that maybe that
is the most important issue but I
wouldn't have guessed it at the time
when I was like eight-year-old
yeah I mean there is
um and you do there's
Folks at open AI including yourself that
do see the importance of these issues to
discuss about them under the big banner
of AI safety that's something that's not
often talked about with the release of
gpt4 how much went into the safety
concerns how long also you spend on the
safety concern can you um can you go
through some of that process yeah sure
what went into uh AI safety
considerations of gpt4 release so we
finished last summer
um we immediately started
giving it to people to uh to Red Team we
started doing a bunch of our own
internal safety efels on it we started
trying to work on different ways to
align it
um
and that combination of an internal and
external effort plus building a whole
bunch of new ways to align the model and
we didn't get it perfect by far but one
thing that I care about is that our
degree of alignment increases faster
than our rate of capability progress
and that I think will become more and
more important over time and
I know I think we made reasonable
progress there to a to a more aligned
system than we've ever had before I
think this is the most capable and most
aligned model that we've put out we were
able to do a lot of testing on it and
that takes a while and I totally get why
people were like give us gpt4 right away
but I'm happy we did it this way is
there some wisdom some insights about
that process that you learned like how
to how to solve that problem you can
speak to how to solve it like the
alignment problem so I want to be very
clear I do not think we have yet
discovered a way to align a super
powerful system we have we have
something that works for our current
skill called our lhf
and we can talk a lot about the benefits
of that and
the utility it provides it's not just an
alignment maybe it's not even mostly an
alignment capability it helps make a
better system a more usable system
and
this is actually something that I don't
think people outside the field
understand enough it's easy to talk
about alignment and capability as
orthogonal vectors they're very close
better alignment techniques lead to
better capabilities and vice versa
there's cases that are different and
they're important cases but on the whole
I think things that you could say like
rlhf or interpretability that sound like
alignment issues also help you make much
more capable models and the division is
just much fuzzier than people think and
so in some sense the work we do to make
gpd4 safer and more aligned looks very
similar to all the other work we do of
solving the research and Engineering
problems associated with creating
useful and Powerful models
so rlhf
is the process that came applied very
broadly across the entire system more
human basically votes what's the better
way to say something
um was you know if a person asks do I
look fat in this dress
there's uh there's different ways to
answer that question that's aligned with
human civilization
and there's no one set of human values
or there's no one set of right answers
to human civilization
so I think what's gonna have to happen
is we will need to agree on as a society
on very broad bounds we'll only be able
to agree on a very broad bounds of what
these systems can do and then within
those maybe different countries have
different rlh F Tunes certainly
individual users have very different
preferences
we launched this thing with gpt4 called
the system message which is not rlhf but
is a way to let users have a good degree
of steerability over what they want and
I think things like that will be
important can you describes this the
message and in general how you were able
to make gpt4 more steerable
foreign
based on the interaction that the user
can have with it which is one of his big
really powerful things so the system
message is a way to say uh you know hey
model please pretend like you or please
only answer this message as if you were
Shakespeare doing thing X or please only
respond uh with Json no matter what was
one of the examples from our blog post
but you could also say any number of
other things to that and then we
we we tune gpt4 in a way to really treat
the system message with a lot of
authority
I'm sure there's jail they'll always not
always hopefully but for a long time
there will be more jailbreaks and we'll
keep sort of learning about those but we
program we develop whatever you want to
call it the model in such a way to learn
that it's supposed to really use that
system message